please welcome aisha curry hi
thank you so much for having me i
love your magazine thank you so much
it's crazy to see it in your hands i
actually can't believe it i'm like gonna
start crying
i just i mean your cookbook your
magazine you have a kitchen line
a home you're you're building um
an empire and a lifestyle brand that we
can all
embrace and then live in and was that
something that you consciously
thought or did it roll out slowly was
your end goal
to rule the world or was it like needs
to get there
i so it's so interesting i'm 30 i'm
going to be 32 um and i feel like it's
been a journey
so i'm finally at the point now
launching sweet july where this is truly
my voice
and my messaging and the whole hope with
it is just for people to find that
bright spot in their life and so sweet
july
is the title and the name of the brand
because all of my kids were born in july
i got married in july
and it's one of the happiest times of my
life and i was like i need to figure out
how to carry that through
every single day it shouldn't just be
one month out of the year
and so the goal is to encourage
everybody to figure out what that sweet
july in their life is and implement
those little things that make them happy
every day
okay not only is that going into my
gratitude list tonight but
that's a real think piece i mean i'm i'm
really beyond uh admiring
everything that you're doing and you are
also
the first woman since oprah that
you know to launch a magazine like this
it's so insane it's so nice and special
and i'm just honored to be able to
you know have space on on the magazine
shelf because i didn't see much of it
um many people that looked like me
growing up when um
when i would go out and look for
magazines so it's just nice to have that
diversity on the shelves
and you're doing it in such an elevated
and chic and beautiful way now
your husband steph curry i mean hashtag
goals both of you
most most i think because of the
work that you do for your community i
literally was like i could spend the
entire time with you
talking about the incredible
accomplishments
that you are doing for others thank you
we um about
almost two years ago now started our
nonprofit eat learn play
um and it couldn't have come at a better
time
because it was right before the pandemic
hit and so we've been able to team up
with our local partners
um to provide meals for kids and their
families were
at almost over 15 million meals just in
the midst of the pandemic and so it's
been
it's been insane um but also devastating
the fact that you know the need keeps
growing and so
we're just trying to stay up as boots on
the ground as possible and keep
everything going but we've been so
grateful to
the community and everybody that's been
willing to step up and and
lend a helping hand because it's not
just us too that's for sure
well it is overwhelming your generosity
and the attention to detail and the
amount that you give and do
however i wanted to ask you really
quickly if he's still drinking the
cranberry juice
draining it uh empty and then putting it
back in the fridge
i was like the audacity like who does
that i was so mad i was so mad and then
he tried to blame it on our
eight-year-old he was like oh i think
i'm like your cup of cranberry juice is
sitting right in front of you
it wasn't her it was you
dad i loved that story
so much